ا
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت
الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا اله الا
الله استووا اعتدلوا
استو
لاذا
استووا الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن
ال الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
[Silence]
امين واذ قال ابراهيم لابيه وقومه
انني
براء مما
تعبدون الا الذي فطرني فانه سيهدي دين
وجعلها كلمه باقيه في عقبه لعلهم
يرجعون بل متعت
هؤلاء
واباءهم حتى جاءهم الحق ورسول
مبين ولما جاءهم الحق قالوا هذا سحر وانا
به كافرون
وقالوا لولا نزل هذا القران على رجل من
القريتين عظيم اهم يقسمون رحمه ربك نحن
قسمنا بينهم معيشتهم في الحياه
الدنيا ورفعنا بعضهم فوق بعض
درجات ليتخذ بعضهم بعضا
سخريا ورفعنا بعضهم فوق بعض درجات ليتخذ
بعضهم بعضا
سخريا ورحمه ربك خير مما
يجمعون ولولا ان يكون الناس امه واحده
لجعلنا لمن يكفر بالرحمن لبيوتهم سقفا من
فضه لبي لبيوتهم سقفا من فض ضه ومعارج
عليها
يظهرون ولبيوتهم
ابوابا وسررا عليها
يتكئون
وزخرفا وان كل ذلك لما متاع الحياه الدنيا
والاخره عند ربك
للمتقين الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
ومن يعش عن ذكر الرحمن نقيض له شيطانا فهو
له
قرين وانهم ليصدونهم عن السبيل ويحسبون
انهم
مهتدون حتى اذا جاءنا قال يا ليت بيني
وبينك بعد المشرقين فبئس
القرين ولن ينفعكم اليوم اذ ظلمتم انكم في
العذاب
مشتركون افانت تسمع الصم او تهدي العمي
ومن كان في ضلال مبين فاما
نذهبن بك فانا منهم
منتقمون او نرينك الذي وعدناهم
فانا عليهم
مقتدرون فاستمسك بالذي اوحي اليك انك على
صراط
مستقيم وانه لذكر لك
ولقومك وسوف
تسالون الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏some
‏happens is there spills and food on the
carpet and then we cannot get that
cleaned because you know if we call a
company to clean itan we cann get dry so
that leaves you know sticky places for
other people who are wor upon it and if
you see somebody doing it you just tell
please step outside don't eat it in
the i remind you again for bottles of
wat them with you every and not exera we
throw aot of water
‏help us main that the most
important is i really want you all to
pay attention to there is a d people
team there is a team of people who
dedicated every night to
serve and i'm a witness there nights
that go by they probably don't get to
eat and they emp because there is so
people serving there not time left
[Silence]
‏come every
‏them
[Silence]
‏so you them if have a
team
not andre you come tell
me i
not as sour
of because i
[Silence]
‏asct
my
one
so take
‏notes everybody fasting
to
and there is a
methy
leading let
in when the from 18 calls ‏we no
ذ not a life or matter if he st for 2
seconds or seconds ors 10 seconds let
him
stop allah says in قراند
فيران comes from stopping and reflecting
to if reading par are inr give time
for themselves to correct themselves to
[Silence]
‏mainan aon
‏let keep light and be kind ز الله
[Silence]
‏v
صلاه التراويح اتاكم الله
استووا
استبو الله اكبر
الله ال
ال الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
ين
امين وانه لذكر لك ولقومك وسوف تسالون
واسال من قد ارسلنا من قبلك من رسلنا
اجعلنا من دون الرحمن الهه يعبد
واسال من ارسلنا من قبلك من رسلنا اجعلنا
من دون الرحمن الهه
يعبدون ولقد ارسلنا موسى باياتنا الى
فرعون وملاه فقال اني رسول رب
العالمين فلما
جاءهم باياتنا اذا هم منها يضحكون
وما نريهم من ايه الا هي اكبر من اختها
واخذنا بالعذاب لعلهم
يرجعون وقالوا يا ايها الساحر ادع لنا ربك
بما عهد عندك اننا لمهتدون
فلما كشفنا عنهم العذاب اذا هم
ينكثون ونادى فرعون في قوم
قال يا قوم اليس لي ملك مصر وهذه الانهار
تجري من تحتي افلا
تبصرون ام انا ام انا خير من هذا الذي هو
مهين ولا يكاد
يبين فلولا القي عليه اسوره من ذهب او جاء
معه الملائكه مقترنين
فاستخف قومه
فاطاعوه انهم كانوا قوما فاسقين فلما
اسفونا انتقمنا منهم فاغرقناهم
اجمعين فجعلناهم سلفا ومثلا
للاخرين ولما ضرب ابن مريم مثلا اذا قومك
منه
يصدون وقالوا الهتنا خير ام هو ما ضربوه
لك الا جدلا بل هم قوم
خصمون ان هو الا عبد انعمنا عليه وجعلناه
مثلا لبني
اسرائيل ولو نشاء لجعلنا منكم
ملائكه في الارض
يخلفون وانه لعلم للساعه فلا تمترن بها
واتبعون هذا صراط مستقيم ولا
يصدنكم الشيطان انه لكم عدو
مبين فلما جاء عيسى بالبينات قال قد جئتكم
بالحكمه ولابين
لكم ولما جاء عيسى بالبينات قال قد جئتكم
بالحكمه ولابين لكم ولابين لكم بعض ولابين
لكم بعض الذي تختلفون فيه فاتقوا الله
واطيعون ان الله هو ربي وربكم فاعبدوه هذا
صراط
مستقيم فاختلف الاحزاب من بينهم فويل
للذين ظلموا من عذاب يوم
اليم هل ينظرون الا الساعه ان تاتيهم بغته
وهم لا
يشعرون
الاخلاء يومئذ بعضهم لبعض عدو الا
المتقين يا عبادي لا خوف عليكم اليوم ولا
انتم تحزنون
الذين امنوا باياتنا و وكانوا
مسلمين الذين امنوا باياتنا وكانوا مسلمين
ادخلوا الجنه انتم وازواجكم
تحبرون يطاف عليهم بصحاف من ذهب
واكواب وفيها ما تشتهيه الانفس وتلذ
الاعين وانتم فيها
خالدون وتلك الجنه التي اورثتموها بما
كنتم
تعملون لكم فيها
فاكهه كثيره منها
تاكلون ان المجرمين في عذاب جهنم خالدون
لا يفتر عنهم وهم فيه مبلسون وما ظلمنا م
ولكن كانوا هم
الظالمين ونادوا يا مالك ليقض علينا ربك
قال انكم
ماكثون لقد جئناكم بالحق ولكن اكثركم للحق
كارهون ام ابرموا امرا فانا مبرمون ام
يحسبون انا لا نسمع سرهم
ونجواهم بلى ورسلنا لديهم
يكتبون قل ان كان للرحمن
ولد فانا اول
العابدين سبحان رب السماوات والارض رب
العرش عما
يصفون فذرهم يخوضوا ويلعبوا حتى يلاقوا
يومهم الذي
يوعدون وهو الذي في السماء اله وفي الارض
اله وهو الحكيم
العليم وتبارك الذي له ملك السماوات
والارض وما بينهما
وعنده علم
الساعه وعنده علم الساعه واليه
ترجعون ولا يملك الذين يدعون من دونه
الشفاعه الا الا من
شهد بالحق وهم
يعلمون واذا قيل لهم من خلق ولئن سالتهم
من خلقهم ليقولن
الله فانا
يؤفكون وقيل يا رب ان
هؤلاء قوم لا
يؤمنون فاصفح عنهم وقل سلام فسوف
يعلمون الله الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
[Silence]
حاميم والكتاب المبين انا انزلناه في ليله
مباركه انا كنا
منذرين فيها يفرق كل امر حكيم امرا من
عندنا انا كنا
مرسلين رحمه من ربك انه هو السميع العليم
رب السماوات والارض وما بينهما ان كنتم
موقنين لا اله الا هو يحيي
ويميت ربكم ورب
ابائكم
الاولين بل هم في شك يلعبون
تقب يوم تاتي السماء بدخان مبين يغشى
الناس هذا عذاب اليم ربنا اكشف عنا العذاب
انا مؤمنون انا لهم الذكرى وقد جاءهم رسول
مبين ثم تولوا عنه وقالوا معلم
مجنون انا كاشف العذاب قليلا انكم
عائدون يوم نبطش البطشه الكبرى انا
منتقمون ولقد فتنا قبلهم قوم فرعون
وجاءهم رسول كريم ان ادوا الي عباد الله
اني لكم رسول
امين واللا تعلوا على الله اني اتيكم
بسلطان
مبين واني عذت بربي وربكم ان ترجمون وان
لم تؤمنوا لي
فاعتزلون فدعا ربه ان هؤلاء قوم مجرمون
فاسر بعبادي ليلا انكم
متبعون واترك البحر رهو انهم جند يغرقون
كم تركوا من جنات
وعيون وزروع ومقام كريم ونعمه كانوا فيها
فاكهين كذلك
واورثناها قوما
اخرين فما بكت عليهم السماء والارض وما
كانوا
منظرين فما بكت عليهم السماء والارض وما
منظرين ولقد نجينا بني
اسرائيل من العذاب المهين من فرعون انه
كان عاليا من المسرفين ولقد اخترناهم على
علم على
العالمين
واتيناهم من الايات ما فيه
بلاء
مبين انها هؤلاء
ليقولون ان هي الا موتتنا الاولى وما نحن
بمنشرين فاتوا
بابائنا ان كنتم
صادقين اهم خير ام قوم تبع والذين من
قبلهم
اهلكناهم انهم كانوا قوما
مجرمين وما خلقنا السما وما خلقنا
السماوات والارض وما بينهما
لاعبين ما خلقناهما الا بالحق ولكن اكثرهم
لا
يعلمون ان يوم الفصل ميقاتهم اجمعين يوم
لا يغني مولا عن مولا شيئا ولا هم
ينصرون الا من رحم
الله انه هو العزيز الرحيم
ان شجره الزقوم طعام الاثيم كالمهل يغلي
في البطون كغلي
الحميم خذوه فاعتلوه الى سواء الجحيم ثم
صبوا فوق راسه ثم صبوا فوق راسه من عذاب
الحميم ذق انك انت العزيز الكريم انها هذا
ما كنتم به
تمترون ان المتقين في مقام
امين في جنات
وعيون يلبسون من سندس واستبرق
متقابلين كذلك وزوجناهم بحور عين يدعون
فيها بكل فاكهه
امنين لا يذوقون فيها الموت الا الموته
الاولى ووقاهم عذاب
الجحيم فضلا من ربك ذلك هو الفوز
العظيم فانما يسرناه بلسانك لعلهم
يتذكرون فارتقب
انهم
مرتقبون الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله ا
[Silence]
استون الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
[Silence]
حاميم تنزيل الكتاب من الله العزيز الحكيم
ان في السماوات والارض لايات
للمؤمنين وفي خلقكم وما يبث من
دابه ايات لقوم
يوقنون واختلاف الليل
والنهار وما انزل الله من السماء من رزق
فاحيا به فاحيا به الارض بعد موتها وتصريف
الرياح وتصريف الرياح ايات لقوم
يعقلون تلك ايات الله نتلوها عليك بالحق
فباي حديث بعد الله واياته
يؤمنون ويل لكل افاك اثيم يسمع ايات الله
تتلى عليه ثم يصر مستكبرا كان لم يسمعها
فبشره بعذاب اليم واذا علم من اياتنا شيئا
اتخذها هزوا اولئك له م عذاب
مهين من
ورائهم جهنم ولا يغني عنهم ما كسبوا شيئا
ولا ما اتخذوا ولا ما اتخذوا من دون الله
اولياء ولهم عذاب
عظيم هذا هدى والذين كفروا بايات ربهم لهم
عذاب من رجز اليم
الله الذي سخر لكم البحر لتجري الفلك فيه
بامره ولتبتغوا من فضله ولعلكم
تشكرون وسخر وسخر لكم ما في السماوات
والارض جميعا منه ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يتفكرون قل للذين امنوا فروا للذين لا
يرجون ايام
الله ليجزي قوما بما كانوا
يكسبون من عمل صالحا فلنفسه ومن اساء
فعليها ثم الى ربكم
ترجعون ولقد اتينا بني
اسرائيل الكتاب والحكم والنبوه
ورزقناهم من الطيبات
ورزقناهم من الطيبات وفضلناهم على
العالمين
واتيناهم بينات من الامر فما اختلفوا الا
من بعد ما
جاءهم العلم بغيا
بينهم ان ربك يقضي بينهم يوم القيامه فيما
كانوا فيه
يختلفون ثم جعلناك على شريعه من الامر
فاتبعها فاتبعها ولا تتبع
اهواء الذين لا
يعلمون انهم لن يغنوا عنك من الله
شيئا وان الظالمين بعضهم
اولياء بعض والله ولي
المتقين هذا بصا
للناس وهدى ورحمه لقوم
يوقنون ام حسب الذين اجترحوا السيئات ان
نجعلهم كالذين امنوا ان نجعلهم كالذين
امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
سواء محياهم
ومماتهم ساء ما
يحكمون وخلق الله السماوات والارض بال حق
ولتجزى كل نفس بما كسبت وهم لا
يظلمون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين افرايت من اتخذ الهه هواه وختم الله
افرايت من اتخذ الهه هواه واضله الله على
علم وختم على سمعه
وقلبه وختم على سمعه وقلب به وجعل على
بصره غشاوه فمن يهديه من بعد
الله افلا
تذكرون وقالوا ما هي الا حياتنا الدنيا
نموت ونحيا وما يهلكنا الا
الدهر وما لهم بذلك من علم ان هم الا
يظنون واذا تتلى عليهم ايات نا بينات ما
كان حجتهم الا ان قالوا ائتوا
بابائنا ان كنتم
صادقين قل الله يحييكم ثم يميتكم ثم
يجمعكم الى يوم القيامه لا ريب
فيه ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون ولله ملك السماوات والارض
ولله ملك السماوات والارض ويوم تقوم
الساعه
يومئذ يخسر
المبطلون وترى كل
امه جاثيه كل امه تدعى الى كتابها اليوم
تجزون ما كنتم
تعملون هذا كتابنا
ينطق عليكم بالحق
انا كنا نستنسخ ما كنتم
تعملون فاما الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
فيدخلهم ربهم في
رحمته ذلك هو الفوز
المبين واما الذين كفروا افلم تكن اياتي
تتلى عليكم فاستكبروا مجرمين
واذا قيل ان وعد الله حق والساعه لا ريب
فيها قلتم ما ندري ما
الساعه قلتم ما ندري ما الساعه ان نظن الا
ظنا وما نحن بمستيقنين
وبدا لهم سيئات ما عملوا وحاق بهم ما
كانوا به
يستهزئون وقيل اليوم ننساكم كما نسيتم
لقاء يومكم هذا وماوا النار وما لكم من
ناصرين ذلكم بانكم اتخذتم ايات الله هزوا
وغرتكم الحياه
الدنيا فاليوم لا يخرجون منها ولا هم
يستعتب
فلله الحمد رب السماوات رب الارض فلله
الحمد رب السماوات ورب الارض رب
العالمين وله
الكبرياء في السماوات والارض وهو العزيز
الحكيم الله ا
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر
السلام عليكم ورح ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
وعلى اله وصحبه ومنوه ومن تبع باحسان الى
يوم
الدين اما بعد
عليه
الصلام
البيا يونس عليه
اللاسلام
عل الله سبحانه
وتالى
علسلام وزك
تنفرض وانتير
وارثين الله
سبحانى عليه الله سبحانه
وتالى الله
‏sometimes you know you know tell th
stories i feel some of you might
think that you know i tell th stories
because i way
people every
time there
a group there one
grou tos
‏any
from there
is in the
way
حجر ربنا اتنا فيدن حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه
‏i because when making you know we
all so loud us that forg youing you know
forg what you saying and saying same
saying and catch not i was asking
[Silence]
‏kind english
under
وتالى عليه
‏zarb عليه
[Silence]
م
عليه عليه
س
[Silence]
‏you asks
a life is
to they fighting so they drew lots
right they pick names and how they pies
they wot them on
sticks andw the
river right and they said theck trav
upam notam is the persons to be the
person raises
‏fl الله
وتالى
fl زكر
عليهه م عليهه
الله المراح
[Silence]
‏in andar ent one and he find is my
words is the qur saying right he finds
platters of
fruits and beauful platters of food and
fruits that are not season and he asks
her how did you get
this
says from الله
‏think maram he by the way this is how
you ask you ask you ask pay attention
you
ask
sayl because we
the is
‏my my all
white so don't me alone have i need to
have a right that succeed me in my work
of don't
me الله سانتال
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله انبياء رب لا ترني فرض وان خير
وارثين do not meon by
my because you are thees the
best personal and i because
[Silence]
‏could
ح ربي لا تذرني فرضا وانت الخير
وارثين الله سبحانه
وتالى
mar don't
know be
respectful right
[Silence]
‏handle
‏there
[Silence]
الحد العال الحد الع الله الحمد
‏as
[Silence]
المست
21 فجبنا له وهبنا له يح وسح
لكر عل
[Silence]
سال life
‏and i was bl time to
person know was was to see the that
[Silence]
اللهبه وتالى
ربنا اتنا في الدن حسنه وفيره حسنه وك
عذاب النار وكنا عذاب القبر وكنا عذاب جنم
وكنا شرف فتنه محيا الممات وكنا شرف فتنه
مسيح الدجال ربنا تقبل من انك انت السميع
العليم وتوب علينا يا مك الرحيم وصلى الله
على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين برحمتك
ارحم الراحمين اللهم امين اللهم امين
اللهم امين جزاك الله
[Silence]
استقيم واعتدلوا استووا سو الصف سدوا
الخلل الله
اكبر اعوذ
بالله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهد الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
حام تنزيل الكتاب من الله العزيز الحكيم
ما خلقنا السماوات والارض وما بينهما الا
بالحق اجل
مسمى والذين كفروا عما انذروا معرضون قل
ارايتم ما تدعون من دون الله اروني ماذا
خلقوا اروني ماذا خلقوا من الارض ام لهم
شرك في السماوات ايتوني بكتاب من قبل هذا
او اثاره من علم ان كن كتم
صادقين ومن اضل ممن يدعو من دون الله من
لا يستجيب له الى يوم القيامه وهم عن
دعائهم
غافلون واذا حشر الناس كانوا لهم
اعداء وكانوا بعبادتهم
كافرين واذا تتلى عل م اياتنا بينات قال
الذين كفروا قال الذين كفروا للحق لما
جاءهم هذا سحر مبين ام يقولون
افتراه قل ان افتريته فلا تملكون لي من
الله شيئا هو اعلم بما تفيضون فيه كفى به
شهيدا بيني وبينكم وهو الغفور الرحيم قل
ما كنت بدعا من الرسل وما ادري ما يفعل بي
ولا
بكم ان اتبع الا ما يوحى الي وما انا الا
نذير مبين قل ارايتم ان كان من ان كان من
عند الله وكفرتم به وشهد شاهد من بني
اسرائيل على مثله فامن
واستكبرتم ان الله لا يهدي القوم
الظالمين وقال الذين كفروا للذين امنوا لو
كان خيرا ما سبقونا اليه واذ لم يهتدوا به
فسيقولون هذا افك قديم ومن قبله كتاب موسى
اماما
ورحمه وهذا كتاب مصدق لسانا عربيا لينذر
الذين ظلموا وبشرى
للمحسنين ان الذين قالوا ربنا الله ثم
استقاموا فلا خوف عليهم ولا هم
يحزنون
اولئك اصحاب الجنه خالدين
فيها خالدين فيها
جزاء بما كانوا
يعملون ووصينا الانسان بوالديه
احسانا حملته امه كرها ووضعته كرها وحمله
وفصاله 30ث
شهرا حتى اذا بلغ اشده وبلغ اعين سنه قال
قال رب اوزعني ان اشكر نعمتك التي انعمت
علي وعلى
والدي وان اعمل صالحا ترضاه واصلح لي في
ذريتي ان اني تبت اليك واني من
المسلمين
اولئك الذين نتقبل عنهم احسن ما
عملوا ونتجاوز عن سيء عن سيئاتهم في اصحاب
الجنه وعد الصدق الذي كانوا
يوعدون والذي قال لوالديه اف لكما ات د
انني
اتعدانني ان اخرج ان اخرج وقد خلت القرون
من
قبلي وهما
يستغيثان الله ويلك امن
ان وعد الله حق فيقول ما هذا الا اساطير
الاولين
اولئك الذين حق عليه م القول في امم قد
خلت في امم قد خلت من قبلهم من الجن
والانس
انهم كانوا
خاسرين ولكل
درجات مما عملوا وليوفيهم
اعمالهم وهم لا
يظلمون ويوم يعرض الذين كفروا على النار
اذهبتم
طيباتكم اذهبتم
طيباتكم في حياتكم الدنيا
واستمتعتم بها فاليوم تجزون عذاب الهون
بما
كنتم تستكبرون في
الارض بما كنتم تستكبرون في الارض بغير
الحق وبما
كنتم
تسقون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر بسم الله الرحمن ال الحمد لله
رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين واذكر اخا عاد اذ انذر قومه بالاحقاف
وقد خلت النذر من بين يديه ومن
خلفه لا تعبدوا الا الله اني اخاف عليكم
عذاب يوم عظيم قالوا اجئتنا لتاف كنا عن
الهتنا فاتنا بما تعدنا ان كنت من
الصادقين قال انما العلم عند الله
وابلغكم ما ارسلت به
ولكني اراكم قوما
تجهلون فلما راوه عارضا مستقبل اديتهم
قالوا هذا عارض
مطرنا بل هو ما استعجلتم به ريح فيها عذاب
اليم تدمر كل شيء بامر ربها فاصبحوا لا
يرى الا مساكنهم
فاصبح فاصبحوا لا يرى الا
مساكنهم كذلك نجزي القوم
المجرمين ولقد
مكناهم في ماء
مكناكم فيه وجعلنا لهم سمعا
وابصارا
وافئده فما اغنى عنهم فما اغنى عنهم سمعهم
ولا ابصارهم ولا افئدتهم من
شيء اذ كانوا يجحدون بايات الله وحاق
بهم ما كانوا به
يستهزئون ولقد اهلكنا ولقد اهلكنا ما
حولكم من
القرى وصرفنا الايات لعلهم
يرجعون فلولا نصر هم الذين اتخذوا من دون
الله قربانا
الهه بل ضلوا
عنهم وذلك افكهم وما كانوا
يفترون واذ صرفنا اليك نفرا من الجن
يستمعون
القران فلما حضروه قالوا
انصتوا فلم ما قضي ولوا الى قومهم
منذرين قالوا يا قومنا انا سمعنا كتابا
انزل من بعد موسى مصدقا لما بين يديه يهدي
الى الحق والى طريق
مستقيم يا قومنا اجيبوا داعي الله وامنوا
به يغفر لكم يغفر لكم من
ذنوبكم
ويجركم من عذاب
اليم ومن لم ومن لا يجب داعي الله فليس
بمعجز في الارض وليس له من دونه
اولياء
اولئك في ضلال
مبين اولم يروا ان الله الذي خلق السماوات
والارض ولم يعي
بخلقهن بقادر بقادر على ان يحيي
الموتى بلى انه على كل شيء قدير ويوم يعرض
الذين كفروا على النار اليس هذا بالحق
قالوا بلى
وربنا قال فذوقوا العذاب بما كنتم
تكفرون فاصبر كما صبر اولو العزم من الرسل
ولا تستعجل
لهم كانهم يوم يرون ما يوعدون لم يلبثوا
الا ساعه من نهار بلى
فهل يهلك الا القوم
الفاسقون بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الذين كفروا وصدوا عن سبيل الله
اضل
اعمالهم والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
وامنوا بما نزل على
محمد وهو الحق من ربهم
كفر عنهم سيئاتهم واصلح بالهم ذلك بان
الذين كفروا اتبعوا الباطل وان الذين
امنوا اتبعوا الحق من ربهم كذلك يضرب الله
للناس
امثالهم فاذا لقيتم الذين كفروا فضرب
الرقاب
فضرب الرقاب حتى اذا اثخنتموهم فشدوا
الوثاق فاما
م بعد واما
فداء حتى تضع الحرب
اوزارها ذلك ولو يشاء الله لانتصر منهم
ولكن ليبلو بعضكم ببعض والذين قتلوا في
سبيل الله فلن يضل
اعمالهم سيهديهم ويصلح بالهم ويدخلهم
الجنه عرفها
لهم يا ايها الذين امنوا ان تنصروا الله
ينصركم ويثبت
اقدامكم والذين كفروا فتس لهم واضل
اعمالهم ذلك بانهم كرهوا ما انزل
الله فاحبط
اعمالهم الله
ا سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب الع العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين افلم يسيروا في الارض في انظروا كيف
كان عاقبه الذين من قبلهم دمر الله عليهم
وللكافرين
امثالها ذلك بان الله مولى الذين امنوا
وان الكافرين لا مولى
لهم ان الله يدخل الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات
جنات جنات
تجري من تحتها
الانهار والذين كفروا يتمتعون وياكلون كما
تاكل
الانعام والنار مثوا
لهم وكاي من قريه هي اشد قوه من قريتك
التي اخرجتك
اهلكناهم اهلكناهم فلا ناصر لهم
من كان على بينه من ربه كمن زين له سوء
عمله واتبعوا
اهواءهم مثل الجنه التي وعد
المتقون فيها انهار من ماء غير اسن
وانهار
وانهار من لبن لم يتغير طعمه وان
وانهار من خمر لذه
للشاربين
وانهار من عسل
مصفى ولهم فيها من كل الثمرات
ومغفره من ربهم كمن هو خالد في النار
وسقوا ماء
حميما وسقوا ما
حميما حميما فقطع
امعاءهم ومنهم من يستمع اليك حتى حتى اذا
خرجوا من عندك قالوا للذين اوتوا العلم
ماذا قال
انفا
اولئك الذين طبع الله على قلوبهم واتبعوا
اهوا
م والذين اهتدوا زادهم هدى واتاهم
تقواهم فهل ينظرون الا الساعه ان تاتيهم
بغته فقد جاء
اشراطها
فانا لهم اذا
جاءتهم
ذكراهم فاعلم
انه لا لا اله الا الله واستغفر
لذنبك واستغفر
لذنبك
وللمؤمنين والمؤمنات
والله يعلم
متقلبكم
ومثواكم ويقول الذين امنوا لولا نزلت سوره
فاذا انزلت سوره محكمه وذكر فيها القتال
وذكر فيها القتال رايت الذين في قلوبهم
مرض ينظرون اليك نظر المغشي عليه من
الموت فاولى لهم طاعه
وقول معروف فاذا عزم الامر فلو صدقوا الله
لكان خيرا لهم فهل عسيتم ان توليتم ان
تفسدوا في الارض وتقطعوا
ارحامكم
اولئك الذين لعنهم الله
فاصمهم واعمى
ابصارهم افلا
يتدبرون
القران افلا
يتدبرون القران ام على قلوب اقفالها
ان الذين ارتدوا على
ادبارهم من بعد ما تبين لهم
الهدى الشيطان سول لهم واملا
لهم ذلك بانهم قالوا للذين كرهوا ما نزل
الله سنطيعكم
سنطيعكم في بعض الامر والله يعلم اس
اسرارهم فكيف اذا توفتهم
الملائكه
يضربون يضربون وجوههم
وادبارهم ذلك
بانهم اتبعوا ما اسخط الله وكرهوا
رضوانه فاحبط
اعمالهم ام حسب الذين في قلوبهم
مرض ام حسب الذين في قلوبهم مرض ان لن
يخرج الله
اضغانهم ولو نشاء
لارينا لاريناكهم فلعرفتهم
بسيماهم
ولتعرفنهم في لحن
القول والله يعلم
اعمالكم و نبلونكم حتى نعلم المجاهدين
منكم
والصابرين ونبلو
اخباركم ان الذين كفروا وصدوا عن سبيل
الله
وشاقوا الرسول من بعد ما
تبين من بعد ما تبين لهم الهدى لن يض ر
الله شيئا
وسيحبط
اعمالهم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يا ايها الذين امنوا اطيعوا الله
واطيعوا الرسول ولا تبطلوا
اعمالكم ان الذين كفروا وصدوا عن سبيل
الله ثم ماتوا وهم
كفار ثم ماتوا وهم كفار فلن يغفر الله لهم
فلا تهنوا وتدعوا الى السلم وانتم
الاعلون والله
معكم ولن يتركم
اعمالكم انما الحياه الدنيا لعب ولهو وان
تؤمنوا
وتتقوا وان تؤمنوا وتتقوا يكم يؤتكم
اجوركم ولا يسالكم
اموالكم ان يسالكموها
فيحفكم فيحفكم تبخل
ويخرج
اضغانكم ها انتم
هؤلاء تدعون لتنفقوا في سبيل الله
فمنكم من يبخل ومن يبخل فانما يبخل عن
نفسه والله الغني
وانتم الفقراء
وان تتولوا يستبدل قوما
غيركم ثم لا يكونوا
امثالكم بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم انا فتحنا لك فتحا
مبينا ليغفر لك الله ما تقدم من ذنبك وما
تاخر ويتم نعمته عليك ويهديك صراطا
مستقيما وينصرك الله نصرا
عزيزا هو الذي انزل السكينه في قلوب
المؤمنين ليزدادوا ايمانا مع
ايمانهم ولله جنود السماوات والارض وكان
الله عليما حكيما ليدخل المؤمنين
والمؤمنات
جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين
فيها ويكفر عنهم
سيئاتهم وكان ذلك عند الله فوزا عظيما
ويعذب المنافقين
والمنافقات والمشركين
والمشركات
والمشركين وال المشركات
الظانين بالله ظن
السوء عليهم
دائره السوء وغضب الله عليهم ولعنهم واعد
لهم جهنم
وساءت
مصيرا ولله جنود السماوات والارض وكان
الله عزيزا حكيما
انا ارسلناك شاهدا
ومبشرا
ونذيرا لتؤمنوا بالله ورسوله وتعزروه
وتعزروه وتوقروه وتسبحوه بكره
واصيلا ان الذين
يبايعونك انما يبايعون الله يد الله فوق
ايديهم فمن نكث
فانما ينكث على
نفسه ومن اوفى بما عاهد عليه الله فسيؤتيه
اجرا
عظيما سيقول لك المخلفون من الاعراب
شغلتنا اموالنا واهلونا فاستغفر لنا
يقولون بالسنتهم
ما ليس في
قلوبهم قل فمن يملك لكم من الله شيئا ان
اراد بكم ان اراد بكم ضرا او اراد بكم
نفعا بل كان الله بما تعملون
خبيرا بل ظننتم ان لن ينقلب الرسول
والمؤمنون الى اهليهم ابدا وزين ذلك في
قلوبكم
وظننتم ظن السوء وكنتم قوما بورا ومن لم
يؤمن بالله ورسوله
فانا فانا اعتدنا
للكافرين سعيرا ولله ملك السماوات والارض
يغفر لمن
يشاء ويعذب من
يشاء وكان الله غفورا رحيما سيقول
المخلفون اذا انطلقتم الى مغانم لتاخذ
ذرونا
نتبعكم يريدون ان يبدلوا كلام الله قل لن
تت
بعونا كذلكم قال الله من قبل
فسيقولون بل
تحسدوننا بل كانوا لا يفقهون الا
قليلا قل للمخلفين من الاعراب ستدعون الى
قوم اولي باس
شديد ستدعون الى قوم اولي باس شديد
تقاتلونهم او
يسلمون فان تطيعوا يؤتكم الله اجرا حسنا
وان تتولوا كما
توليتم من قبل
يعذبكم يعذبكم عذابا
اليما ليس على الاعمى حرج ولا على الاعرج
حرج ولا على المريض حرج
ومن يطع الله ورسوله يدخله
جنات يدخله
جنات تجري من تحتها
الانهار ومن يتولى
يعذبه
عذابا
اليما الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكب
اكب
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏st اعتدل
السو الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستق ستقيم صراط
الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
والعاديات ضبحا فالموريات
قدحا فالمغيرات
صبحا فاثرن به نقعا فوسطن به جمعا
ان الانسان لربه
لكنود وانه على ذلك
لشهيد وانه لحب الخير
لشديد افلا يعلم اذا بعثر ما في القبور
وحصل ما في
الصدور ان
ربهم بهم يومئذ لخبير
الله
اكب سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين تبت يدا ابي لهب وتب ما اغنى عنه
ماله وما كسب سيصلى
نارا ذات لهب
وامراته
حماله الحطب في جيدها حبل
من
مسد الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم يد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله
ا سمع الله لمن
حمده اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد في الاولين
وصل على سيدنا محمد في الاخرين وصل على
سيدنا محمد في كل وقت
وحين وصل على سيدنا محمد حتى ترث الارض
ومن عليها وانت خير
الوارثين اللهم اعز الاسلام والمسلمين
واعلي رايتي الحق والدين المبين وارحم
وانصر
اوليائك المستضعفين
اللهم تم نورك فهديت فلك الحمد عظم حلمك
فعف
فلك الحمد بسطت يدك فاعطيت فلك الحمد
اللهم يا ربنا ويا مولانا ويا سميع الدعاء
يا ذا المن والعطاء يا ذا الجلال
والاكرام يا حي يا
قيوم يا بديع السماوات
والارض ويا رحمن الدنيا والاخره
ورحيمهما اللهم اهدنا في من هديت وعافنا
في من عافيت وتولنا في من توليت وبارك لنا
فيما اعطيت واصرف عنا برحمتك شر ما قدرت
وقضيت انك تقضي بالحق ولا يقضى عليك انه
لا يذل من واليت ولا يعز من عاديت تباركت
ربنا
وتعاليت اللهم انا نسالك من الخير كله
عاجله
واجله ما علمنا منه وما لم نعلم ونعوذ بك
من الشر كله عاجله
واجله ما علمنا منه وما لم نعلم اللهم
اصلح لنا ديننا الذي هو عصمه امرنا واصلح
لنا دنيانا التي فيها
معاشنا واصلح لنا اخرتنا التي اليها
معادنا واجعل اللهم الحياه الدنيا زياده
لنا في كل خير والموت راحه لنا من كل شر
اللهم اجرنا من خزي الدنيا وعذاب الاخره
اللهم اعتق رقابنا ورقاب ابائنا من النار
ورقاب ابائنا وامهاتنا وازواجنا وريات
واصحابنا وم
ومشايخنا ومن لهم كل الحقوق علينا ومن
احبنا فيك واحببناه فيك اللهم اعتق رقابنا
جميعا من النار اللهم بلغنا ليله القدر
واجعلنا فيها من
المقبولين واجعلنا فيها من النار من
المعتوقين برحمتك يا ارحم الراحم
ربنا هب لنا من ازواجنا
وذرياتنا قره اعين واجعلنا للمتقين اماما
ربنا اصرف عنا عذاب جهنم ان عذابها كان
غراما ربنا تقبل منا انك انت السميع
العليم وتب علينا يا ربنا انك انت التواب
الرحيم اللهم اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
والتابعين واخر دعوانا ان الحمد لله رب
العالمين الله
اكبر الله الله
اك الله